- Hello Believe Nation.
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the
major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from Pastor Sunday Adalaja
and my take on his top
10 rules for success.
Rule number four is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
and when you write it
down it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(rocket taking off)
(empowering music)
- Stop pitying yourself.
Stop pitying yourself.
Stop looking at yourself as a victim.
That is one thing you must stop doing
if you want to attain anything in life.
You know what.
Life is about pain.
Everybody one time or
the other feels pain.
And if you are afraid of pain or you want
to run away from pain all the time,
that means you pity yourself too much.
And if you run away too much from pain,
then you will not
have any progress
or you will not experience
any change in life whatsoever.
Every change requires pain.
For example, if you want to
sit down at home and study
and not watch TV,
and not go to play with your friends,
that costs something,
that causes some pain.
If you want to be
different from other people
people that criticize
you and talk about you,
that causes some pain.
But those pain are what
I call voluntary pains.
They are pains that you need
to pay the price of right now
so that you'll be able
to avoid greater pain
later on in life.
But if you are somebody
that likes comfort too much
and you think that any
correction or any process of pain
is too much for you or is deadly for you,
or is unbearable for you,
you will only be pitying yourself.
And if all you're doing
is just pitying yourself,
you will never become a better person.
Sometimes we all need to
be tough on ourselves.
Be tough on yourself.
Get your flesh out of that bed
and go do what you need to do.
Sometimes you need to
force your flesh to listen.
Don't let the flesh
have dominion over you.
Get to doing what you need to do
and let that flesh feel that pain
so that you might get the
results you desire in your life.
Stop pitying yourself.
Success is one thing that is hidden
in the most unlikely of places.
And one of the places
that success is hidden
is in doing what you
don't feel like doing.
Most of the time, we do
what we feel like doing
and we don't do what we
don't feel like doing.
Just like a kid or a child
that doesn't want to wake up
in the morning to go to school.
But you make them go to school
because that is the way to success.
Success, the same thing with
adults, a failure is somebody
that gives to his flesh and
to his body what they want.
Your body wants to eat chocolate
and ice cream all the time,
you eat it all the time.
You do what you feel like doing.
Well that will lead you to being obese.
If you feel like going to work, you go.
But if you don't feel
like going, you don't go.
Or if you feel like studying, you study.
But if you don't feel like
studying, you don't study.
If you do what you feel
like doing all the time,
you'll become a failure in life.
But in life you've got to
do what you need to do.
You've got to do what you
don't feel like doing.
If it needs to be done, if
you need to study, you study
even if you don't feel like studying.
And if you need to go to
work, even if you don't feel
like going to work, you go to work
because that is the right thing to do.
So successful people are people who force
themselves to do the right thing to do.
They force themselves to
do what they need to do
rather than going out there
to do only what they feel like doing.
But they actually do what
they don't feel like doing
because they know it is needed to be done.
So if you really want
to be successful in life
don't look for the easy
things in life to do.
Look for the things that are difficult
even if you don't feel like doing it.
But when you do it anyway,
that is the quickest way to success
when you break your flesh,
when you humble your desires
and you go to do the
things that you need to do
even if you don't feel like doing it.
Well, success is hidden
in the most impossible of places.
In the place of pain when
you go to do the things
that you don't feel like
doing, you'll find success.
You know the best victory
you could ever have,
the number one enemy you need to conquer
is yourself.
Many people are busy trying
to conquer some principalities
and powers and fight some demons
and fight some curses,
you know, inherited curses,
generational curses they call them.
If you're a Christian, you
don't need to bother so much
about your generational curses.
Maybe some people might
be having that problem,
but you know what I discovered.
I discovered that you and yourself
is the biggest fight of your life.
You need to conquer yourself first.
You need to put yourself
in place and begin to talk
to yourself, "I will change myself.
"I must change my habits.
"I must work on my weaknesses.
"I must become a better
person for myself."
Most of our challenges,
most of our troubles
are connected to us.
If we are not the sole person
totally or wholly responsible
for whatever we are going
through, one way or the other
there is a place, there is a role
that we ourselves have played in it.
And if we don't take the,
if the majority of the blame
doesn't go to us,
it still doesn't matter,
because some percentage of
the blame still goes to us.
So it's better to focus on ourselves
and focus and see what amount
of the blame do I carry.
And then try to work on
yourself to eliminate
and to remove some of those
things that have led you
to that trouble you are
in in the first place.
So the first work you can do in this work
is to work on yourself.
The first victory you gain in this work
is the victor of yourself.
You're over yourself so let us consider
talking to ourselves
and working on ourselves
rather than being concerned
about other people.
You are the biggest enemy of your life
and, you know what, many
of us have some dreams,
great dreams, and many of
us have some aspirations,
great aspirations, and
many of us are dreaming
of becoming great people,
dreaming of doing a lot of great stuff,
but unfortunately, what
I've discovered is that
most of the time if we
don't conquer ourselves,
we cannot conquer the world around us.
A man that would conquer
the world must first of all
conquer himself.
Have you talked about that?
Have you really conquered yourself?
You need to conquer yourself first
before you can think of
going to conquer the world.
And if you don't work on yourself,
if you don't perfect yourself,
if you don't train yourself,
if you don't discipline yourself,
if you don't tutor yourself,
if you don't administrate yourself,
if you don't manage
yourself, you will discover
that you will not be effective in managing
any of that person out there
and you will not be effective
in managing any of that
fame outside there.
So for us to conquer the world,
we must conquer ourselves.
As a matter of fact, only the
people that have conquered
themselves eventually
rule over this world.
Only people who have conquered themselves
conquer the world.
Only the people who have
overcome and gained victory
over themselves are the
people that have authority
in the world because they
don't have the same challenges.
They don't have the same issues.
Well, you might say there are some people
who have not conquered themselves
but are successful in the world.
But that success is
temporal, it's temporary.
Most of those people, they are disgraced
out of those successes.
Eventually success will
become sorrow to you
if you don't conquer yourself
because it will be revealed
and you'll be exposed eventually.
You've got to surround
yourself with the right people
for you to be truly successful.
For example if you want
to become a politician,
make sure that you surround yourself,
you go and find an environment,
a suitable environment,
where you can learn from
the politicians and where
the politicians to help you
to advance in your calling
and in your destiny.
If you want to become a
businessman, surround yourself,
find yourself, get yourself
to where business people are.
An environment is a major key to success.
It's actually one of the most
important factor to success.
It's more important than preparation.
It's more important than knowledge.
It's very important.
You cannot underestimate the
role of environment in success.
So you need to find people who are already
in the place where you wish to be.
Even if you don't have people like that
in your surroundings
or in your environment.
If you need to be a politician
and there are no politicians
around you, go and read
books of politicians.
Surround yourself with books
or tapes of great politicians.
Learn from them.
That is environment.
Create the environment for yourself.
If you don't have millionaires around you
and you want to become a millionaire,
get the books and literature
of the millionaires
around the world, learn from them
and create the environment of success.
And surround yourself with the environment
of a millionaire and
you will discover that
this is possible.
This is a major factor
to being successful.
So success is available
and attainable.
Success is always hidden in
the most unlikely of places.
One of the places where success
is hidden really is in work.
It's in the ability to
work hard, and work smart,
and work more.
Work is one of the major
instruments for success.
Really you cannot find a
truly successful person
who doesn't like to work.
You cannot find a truly successful person
who is not a workaholic.
For you to really be successful in life,
you've got to love to work.
And work you must, not just any how,
because many people work really
and many people work hard.
But you've got to work smart.
The difference between
working smart and working hard
is to get enough knowledge
about what you want to do
before you begin to do it.
And when you start to
do it, you do it hard.
And when you're doing
more, and work even harder,
there's no way success could escape you.
So if you really want to be successful,
learn not just to work, but learn to work
by gaining first
knowledge about the nature
of the work you want to do.
And to be able to work smartly, to be able
to do things strategically.
And working smart is the
kind of work that you do
when you focus on the
results, on the result
that you will get at the end of the day.
And you focus on that and you work aiming
to get the result that you are targeting,
not just work for the sake of working.
And of course working hard.
It's not to work just eight hours a day.
It's to work for as long
as possible just to get
to where you want to get to.
So working hard, working
smart, and working more
is the key to success.
You must stop trying to
be someone you are not.
You must stop playing games on yourself
and on other people.
You know what most people do around us.
They paint a picture of
who they are really not.
That's why it's a big thing to dress
when you are going out of the house.
Why do you want to dress?
Well, you do the makeup,
remove some of the rashes.
It's good to do those
things but most of the time,
we dress to create the wrong impression.
We look, we behave to create an impression
rather than be who we are.
Because we are scared of who we are.
We are even scared of accepting
ourselves for who we are.
So we live a deceptive lifestyle.
We're deceiving other people
about the truth about us.
Some people have deceived
themselves so much,
they don't even know
who they are any more.
So to really improve your life
and make your life better,
you must stop trying to be
who and what you are not.
Stop trying to create an impression.
Stop trying to impress everybody.
Stop trying to make everybody accept you.
Stop trying to put on a show.
Stop being an actor.
Come to realize who you are,
and come to accept who you are.
And if you are not good enough,
begin to work on yourself
to make yourself good enough.
If you don't like how you are,
face it.
That is how you are and
it is the starting point
of making yourself better.
Stop being who you are not.
Stop lying. Stop playing games.
And stop deceiving the world and yourself.
Then you can begin to make
yourself a better you.
If you have the right
information about success
or if you know the factors of success,
it's easy for you to attain success,
to be successful, and to become everything
that you wish to become in life.
You just need to get
the right information.
That is why knowledge
is to gather that power.
Knowledge is power.
For those people who know the importance
and the significance of knowledge,
their lives never remains the same.
They are never the same wherever they are.
No matter where you are, even
the darkest village in Africa,
if you can lay your hand on knowledge,
if you can go for information,
information has the ability to exalt you.
Information and knowledge
has the ability to raise you
out of darkness and put you into the light
and on top of your world.
Information makes the whole difference.
When information comes to you,
it just displaces darkness
and it brings you into
the top of your world.
So one of the first factors of success,
and that makes success available to you,
is to make yourself informed.
Inform yourself, go for knowledge.
Be hungry for knowledge.
Be thirsty for knowledge.
Be on the adventure for knowledge.
If you go for knowledge,
if you look for knowledge,
you will see that you will never remain
where life has put you.
You will always move forward
and you will be closer to success.
And success will become
such a reality to you
than you could ever imagine.
The greatest wealth that
you can ever think of
is the wealth of time.
Time is the greatest thing that you have,
you and I have in our lives.
Because time itself is equal to life.
Time is more than money.
Time is more than gold.
Time is more than precious silver.
Time is equal to life.
Because our life itself
is a totality of time.
So if we say a child is born,
that child actually has life in himself.
And we say the child is
10 years old for example.
Or we say the child is 20 years old,
the person is 20 years old,
that 20 years that we refer to,
or that five years we refer to,
or 10 years that we refer to,
is a subtotal of time.
So if I'm say 40 years
old, or 43 years old,
that is a subtotal of the
amount of time that I've lived.
So that time equals my life.
So time is life and most of
what you do with your time
is what you do with your life.
So if you waste your time,
you're actually wasting your life.
So if you value your time, you
value your life eventually.
Because life is the greatest commodity,
it's the greatest blessing,
it's the greatest treasure
that heaven has given
to all of us on earth.
So if you really want
to be a valuable person,
you must value your time.
If you want people to value
you and to respect you,
you must respect yourself
by respecting your time.
You have to think of what
you do with your time
on a daily basis.
How do you spend your time?
Do you waste your time?
If you waste your time,
you waste your life.
other people will waste
your time and your life as well.
So wasting time is actually an abuse.
If you don't want to abuse yourself,
don't want to abuse your life,
the best thing to do is to think about it
and begin to value every
minute of your day.
Don't just go about and talk.
Don't just go about and do
just anything out there.
Think twice and calculate
the way you spend your time
and think about it
before you do something.
Thinking in terms of time is life.
Everything that you have
now might be insignificant,
might be small, but it is
those things that you have now
that will be a blessing to you tomorrow.
If you want anything big in your life,
if you want anything big to
come to you, it will only come
from the little things
that you have right now.
Big stuff will not come
to you from outside,
or from the moon, or from somewhere
when you've never had it.
The big things you will
ever have in your life
will grow out of the little little things
you have right now,
out of the small things
that you have in your hand.
So whatever you have in your hand,
you've got to treasure them.
Whatever things you have in your hand,
you've got to value.
And then not just value and treasure,
but you've got to nurture
the small things you have.
Because the big things
that will come to you
will normally come and only will come
through those small
things that are right now
in your hand and in your care.
As you are faithful in
them, they will become big.
If you really want to
be great and successful,
you've got to admit the
needs of other people.
You've got to go and help
other people meet their needs.
To be the servant of all, if
you want to be the greatest,
it means go and help somebody
else resolve their problems.
So the act of success is
when we are able to identify
problems of other people
and go to help them
to resolve those problems.
So success is in resolving problems.
Success is when we resolve, when we help
to solve other people's
challenges and problems.
So if you want to really be successful,
well go on a search.
Go on a search for
problems and for situations
where people are having
needs or difficulties,
and go and prepare yourself and find a way
of meeting those needs and
resolving those problems
of people.
As you bring your services
or goods that will resolve
the problem of these
people, you will discover
that they begin to thank
you, they begin to show
their appreciation in
forms of remuneration,
salary, honorarium.
One way or the other
they'll begin to pay you
or compensate you for your
efforts and for your services.
So when your purpose in
doing this is not just
to get the money or to get remuneration,
if you just go to resolve the problems
and to provide solution and answers,
you will discover that you keep on getting
more skills and you keep on
getting more recognition,
and not just recognition
and skills, but you
keep on getting salary
or money or compensation
for your efforts.
And that will keep on lifting you up.
The more you do, the more
you sacrifice yourself
for others, the more that
you experience real success.
So success is going to
find a need and meet it.
And success will
automatically come to you.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Nikiru Ojimadu asked me to.
So if there's someone
you'd like me to cover
in the next top 10
video, check out the link
in the description and
go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Skip Prichard.
Skip, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and taking that picture
and posting it to your Twitter.
I really really appreciate the support
and I hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.
- You've got to be proactive.
You've got to be proactive
and become a person of action
if you really want to attain success.
If you really want to be
successful and move forward
in anything you do in your whole life,
you've got to make sure that
you're a person of action.
That you are proactive,
you don't wait for people
to tell you what to do.
You don't wait to get
the command from anybody.
But you stand and go and
do what you need to do.
You be proactive, you initiate changes.
You initiate a move.
You be ready to go out and
do as much work as possible.
Be a person of action.
The Bible tells us that the
hand of the lazy brings poverty,
but the hand of the diligent
brings wealth and riches.
Be diligent in everything you do.
Be a person of diligence.
Be somebody that will do.
You know, if you need
to work for eight hours,
work for 10 hours.
If you need to do 10 works, do 20 works.
Just make sure that you
act and you do better
than any other person around.
You know, when I was in the university,
when I came from Africa
to study in Europe,
I knew for me to get anywhere
I must become the best student
in university.
I must beat all the students
from every other country
because I'm a black person.
And if I really want to make
a difference in this world,
if I really want to make a lasting impact,
if I want my Jesus to be proud of me,
and if I don't want for
Him to be ashamed of me
or for the world to be ashamed
of Him, I must make sure
that I study extra class, extra time,
and that's the key to become
the best in your field.
So be proactive and be a person of action,
and success will be
available and ready for you.
Preparation is the key and a major key
to success in life.
You can become great in life.
You can become successful in life.
Only be adequately prepared.
Many people do things shabbily.
Many people do things on the surface.
Many people just do things to get by
and to just get the mark
that they have done it.
People go to school and just do exams
as if they are doing it for the teacher.
People go to school and just
play around in the school.
People go to universities
and don't give their best.
They are not adequately prepared
and they are still dreaming
and yet they are dreaming
of being successful in life.
Well, success is not
possible to just anybody.
Success comes to people who
fulfill conditions of success.
Success comes to people
who do and abide themselves
by the laws of success.
Yesterday we spoke about
the law of information
and the power of knowledge, and the role
it plays in success.
But today we're talking about
the importance of preparation.
You need to get yourself prepared.
You need to be the best you
can be in everything you do.
You need to make sure that you don't just
jump into doing something.
But you make sure that you
first of all prepare yourself.
You make sure you have
an adequate preparation
before you start to embark on
any journey or any activity
or anything whatsoever you do.
That's the principle that
the sports people use,
sportsmen who win the Olympics.
They use, spend maybe two,
three, four years preparing.
Some spend up to five, 10
years preparing themselves
rigorously before they go and compete
in whatever sports they're competing in.
So preparation is a womb to success.
Preparation is the womb of success.
So let's get prepared adequately
before we engage in anything.
That is another major factor to success.
If you really want to be successful,
you must begin diligent enough
to go through the process.
Many people just want
to wake up one morning,
and just wake up being
successful, or wake up being big,
wake up being great, and
just have everything at once.
No, that is deception.
You cannot have everything just at once.
You must be willing and
ready to painstakingly
go through the process of production.
You must not be one of
those ones that want to have
something for nothing.
You must not be one of those people
that want to have
something where you don't
pay the price for it.
You must be willing to
pay the price for anything
that you desire to have in life.
Don't just have a goal,
but be willing to work
and go through the process of pain,
of endurance, of sacrifice,
of labor, of work.
Just make sure you follow the order.
Make sure you follow the rules.
Make sure you follow due
process so that you'll be able
to get where you want to go.
Because that is the only
thing that can assure you
or give you a lasting success.
So you must be a person of process.
You must be thorough.
You must be diligent.
You must learn to pay attention to details
and to minute insignificant things.
So you must pay attention to
the details and the process
of creation, the process of production,
the process from getting from a to b.
You must be thorough.
You must make sure that
you follow the rules.
you don't omit any single
or any small point in your
quest to go and get to where
you wish to find yourself.
So be a thorough, diligent person.
Diligence and being thorough
to follow through the process
is a major factor to
becoming successful in life